[Musique]
Marina bonjour nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne Youtube qui
s'appelle on aurait aimé un petit peu
avoir votre lecture et votre prisme de
lecture sur les interventions militaires
dans le monde et les relations
internationales est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement quel
parcours vous avez bien sûr je suis
actuellement prof à l'Université
Northwestern qui se situe à Chicago aux
États-Unis et aussi professeur invité à
Sciences pour Paris euh je suis de
l'origine allemande mais j'ai fait
toutes mes études à l'extérieur euh
d'allemne je j'ai passé mon premier
cycle ici en France à scienceces pour
Paris notamment et ensuite je suis parti
aux États-Unis j'ai un doctorat de
Princeton et euh après de Princeton je
suis donc euh allée à Chicago pour
enseigner les relations internationales
là-bas et mon expertise c'est euh les
relations internationales mais notamment
euh la sécurité internationale et les
interventions militaires qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire dessus en ce
moment euh en Europe en Afrique
qu'est-ce qui se passe bon tout d'abord
euh les interventions les interventions
militaires c'est vraiment quelque chose
euh qui arrive très souvent hein alors
euh depuis la Second Guerre mondiale il
y avait plus moins 150 euh interventions
militaires multilatérales hein là il y a
toujours un distinction entre les
multilatéral et les les les
interventions qui's ont juste mené par
un État comme par exemple la France ou
euh les États-Unis moi je suis notamment
experte des relations internationales
multilatérales al donc je m'intéresse
aussi pour pour les pour les
interventions qui sont mené en
coalition mais là actuellement bien
entendu il y a des interventions un peu
partout comment ça se passe le
financement par exemple de ces
interventions là c'est clair c'est
transparent est-ce que le public est au
courant de comment c'est financé bon il
faut savoir que pour n'importe quelle
coalition
il y a jamais un vrai consensus une
convergence
d'intérêt alors si on voit par exemple
20 pays qui participent dans l'opération
de
l'Otan en Libye on peut plus ou moins
assumer que peut-être il y a deux trois
pays qui qui s'intéressent vraiment pour
pour cette opérationquel lesquel bon
pour la Libye c'était la France et
l'Angleterre et et le trè et le 3è c'est
c'est tout ça c'est tout comment ça
s'est financé tout ça bon euh c'était en
opération de l'OTAN hein alors l'OTAN
n'a pas de financement autonome l'ONU
a un budget qui ensuite finance euh les
enfin les soldats en grosin directement
directement ouais il y a par cash par
virement par comment il y a euh un un
budget pour les opérations onusiennes et
et ensuite chaque État chaque soldat qui
qui envoyé par un État membre de l'ONU
reçoit à peu près 100300 dollars par
mois hein et ensuite l'ONU rembourse
aussi le frais pour l'équipement hein
par exemple pour nimporte
quel voiture
hélicoptère même pour les radios hein il
y a il y a de de frais qui sont
remboursés aux États et donc pour cela
il y a quelques états par exemple l'Inde
le bangladesch
Népal moi je dirais aussi
l'Uruguay qui qui reçoivent beaucoup
d'argent on participant dans ces
attvenm les les Népalais ils envoient
ils envoient des soldats ils sont en
tong les gens quand ils arrivent voilà
il faut les équiper ouais euh mais
ensuite bien
entendu pour par exemple les opérations
de l'OTAN ou aussi de de l'Union
africaine même de de l'Union européenne
où les gens enfin où les les opérations
aussi qui ont mené
ad HOG ça veut dire
sans un cadre institutionnel les
financements viennent d'autres d'autres
sources comment c'est quoi quelle source
par exemple
l'opération de l'Union africaine qui qui
se déroule en ce moment en Somalie là
c'est presque entièrement l'Union
européenne qui pe pour les les les gens
de au f les soldats de
Uganda Rwanda d'autres pays africains
d'y participer c'est l'équivalent d'un
proxy c'est une guerre par procuration
c'est c'est l'équivalent d'un
mercenariat
ou là il faut vraiment distinguer parce
que normalement le le terme mercenariat
c'est toujours attaché à des firmes
privées mais là ce sont vraiment des
gouvernements hein qui encaissent
l'argent d'autres gouvernements alors si
on veut parler d'un marché hein c'est
vraiment un marché entre gouvernement
hein et là par exemple en Somalie il y a
des des pays riches
dirais notamment l'Union européenne qui
veut que la situation se tranquillise
notamment parce que nous avons des
intérêts
de pour les minéux le commerce il y a
beaucoup
de navire qui passent par le
canal Aden et mais pour les Européens F
un soldat européen très cher hein ici le
public est très critique
et et notamment par rapport à la Somalie
parce qu'il avait peut-être vous
connaissez cette histoire de Black HD
euh où il y avait des Américains qui ont
étaient voilà tués et ensuite c'était un
peu le désastre par c'était c'était
vraiment dans l'œil public international
et donc là il y a une préférence de
payer des soldats de du Uganda par
exemple au lieu de de d'envoyer un sur
la français all l'opinion publique coûte
très cher c'est ça il faut il faut que
l'opinion publique occidentale
on préserve ces soldats télévisuellement
c'est ça oui mais je crois il y a aussi
des motifs économiques alors là
le les salaires disons sont le suivant
le l'Union européenne pe à peu près 1200
dollars par mois par soldat hein qui
sert ça représente quel volume total
euh là pour le ENF c'était
500000 500 millions
d'euros que l'Union européenne a payé
pour en
25 plus moins qu'en 2015 qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez me dire de l'OTAN est-ce que
l'OTAN a une politique prédatrice et
est-ce que l'OTAN n'est pas devenu
l'irsat de la politique étrangère
américaine face à la Russie la Chine
l'Inde peut-être même l'Europe euh non
non
je vous raconte un peu de de l'opération
en Libye en 2011 c'était la enfin je
peux vous parler aussi de l'opération en
Afghanistan ISAF CIT aussi une opération
gigantesque de
l'OTAN mais je trouve l'opération en
Libye c'est plus intéressant peut-être
alors du coup ce qu'il faut vraiment
savoir des interventions militaires
toujours euh en gros c'est une politique
comme par exemple une politique
commerciale dans le commerce on sait
toujours il y a des gagnants et des
perdantsin là si on va lib et
complètement le commerce de
l'agriculture en France il y aura des
gagnants peut-être des consommateurs
mais il y a sûrement aussi des perdants
euh des petits agriculteurs ils en
France et par rapport aux interventions
militaires on a toujours l'impression
que une telle division d'avantage
n'existe pas hein parce que c'est la
sécurité alors tout le monde va en
bénéficier mais en gros pour les
interventions militaire il y a
exactement la même division il a des
gagnants il a des groupes d'intérêts qui
va en profiter plus il a autes qui vont
perdre alors qui sont ces gagnants deant
enfin ça peut être bien sûr des des des
entreprises du pétrole de l'uranium
euh les les l'entreprise de défense mais
aussi ensuite des organisations
humanitaires quelqu'un par exemple qui
milite dans une organisation enfin qui
enfin qui s'intéresse pour le droit de
l'homme retire plus comme un économiste
je dirais plus de
utilité que quelqu'un qui milite dans
une organisation de l'environnement par
exemple parce que là qu' qu'on
longend
éantenu en Libye c'était quand même
aussi avec quelques raisons humanitaires
lesquel bon on voulait on voulait sauver
les gens de Bengazi apporter la
démocratie pour les petites filles oui
pour le psifi et je crois c'était
surtout voilà on avait vraiment peur que
que ça vraiment
Blad euh sur le conflit libien quand
même il y a il y a des zones d'ombre par
rapport à kadfi et l'intervention de
Sarkozi en Libye c'était pas piloté à
votre avis oui et pour cela c'est alors
pour vraiment comprendre cette
intervention il faut regarder quel
groupe d'intérêts ont poussé pour cette
intervention hein et euh surtout en
France il y a comme une tradition que il
y a toujours un mélange entre groupes
humanitaires je dirais et ensuite groupe
euh
business/ défense militaire et et quand
on B quand on associe les deux est-ce
que ça crée une dialectique du type
bombardement
humanitaire intervention extérieure
humanitaire ou alors ça c'est une chose
extrêmement important parce qu'en fait
euh vu qu'il y a deux groupes qui sont
extrêmement différents hein euh mais
quand même au moment euh quand il pousse
t ensemble pour cette intervention il
collaborè il collabor très très bien
mais ensuite une fois l'intervention est
fait les objectifs divergent
extrêmément pour cela le afterm des
interventions est tellement
catastrophique par exemple en Irak on
avait en gros trois groupes aux
États-Unis qui voulaient l'intervention
en Irak alors c'était l'intervention en
2003 les néonservateurs oui il avait
néoconservateurs mais là aussi il avait
deux groupes à
de
cette il avait les gens qui voulai
montrer de la force parce que considérit
que toute cette époque Clinton et même B
P l'Amérique était faible une des des
grandes idées néoconservateur c'est
weak la faiblesse provocante voilà et
donc il faut
la force américaine et l'Afghanistan
c'était pas encore suffisant alors pour
eux le seul objectif de l'intervention
en Irak c'était démontrer de la force et
détruire en 2 semaines toute l'armée
irakienne parce que l'armée irakienne
était quand même encore un ennemie
considérable hein c'était pas c'était
pas des des
petits talibans avec des avec des
danquis avec des armes n'importe quoi ça
c un groupe juste montrer de la force il
y avait un autre groupe qui voulait
vraiment construire de la démocratie
quel quel groupe ça c'était autour de
condolisaris wolfovitz ce so wolfovitz
voulait faire de la démocratie avec
condolis ouais ils étaient condolisaris
c'était quelqu'un qui qui a grandi
intellectuellement pendant la fin de la
guerre froide he et là il avait le
moment euh
que de la ça s'appelle
democratic peace theory hein alors si
tous les régimes autoritaires tombent on
va tous vivre en paix partout dans le
monde qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de la doctrine de
Brezinski qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
quelle doctrine
interventionniste mais
l'interventionnisme pour pour des
objectifs notamment de construire des
démocraties de ce qu'on nous en dit
que j'ai pas l'impression en fait que
toutes les interventions étaient motivé
comme vous nous l'avez démontré que par
des intérêts humanitaires la la question
que nous on se pose c'est vraiment il n
a est-ce qu'il y a pas un plan vraiment
plus à long terme un un un plan
stratégique à 30 ans de soit conquête
soit de déstabilisation quand on a vu la
ceinture méditerranéenne s'embraser avec
la Tunisie l'Égypte et que en Égypte on
a retrouvé des gens américains avec le
parfait petit kit du révolutionnaire
c'est-à-dire du cage des CD de la
propagande écrite et de quoi imprimer
tout ça on se pose la question est-ce
que ces guerresl ne sont pas aussi
stimulées pour créer un contrefeu
économique en face de l'Europe
c'estàdire empêcher l'Europe de se
projeter économiquement sur ces nouveaux
marchés qui seraient naturel par les
États-Unis et ensuite un isolationnisme
américain on peut le voir ils sont en
train de se retirer un peu partout parce
que c'est compliqué ils recentrent leur
budget militaire en Europe le Pentagone
a multiplié par 4 son budget
d'intervention pour l'année prochaine
pour contrer influence de la Russie
paraît-il donc la question réellement
qu'on se pose c'est est-ce que les
Américains n'ont pas une stratégie en
deux temps c'est-à-dire mettre le feu
faire la politique de la terre brûlée en
face de chez nous et ensuite dire bon
vous débrouillez vous avez les flux de
migrants qui débarquent chez vous c'est
pas bien grave euh la Syrie l'Irak
l'Afghanistan c'est un vrai bourbier
mais on va laisser ça comme ça parce que
bon bah on sait pas comment faire puis
de toutes les façons il y en a pour
tellement cher et pendant tellement
d'années que on a des des des
interventions électorales à respecter ou
des échéances électorales à respecter
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez s'il y a
pas de de politique on va dire c'est pas
si amment fait le déstabilisation de
tous ces
pays
euh vous savez on a beaucoup parlé
de de cette
théorie aussi par rapport au 11
septembre alors vous faites référence
aux déclarations de Westley Clark le
général Wesley Clark nonf voilà partout
dans l'Internet partout il y a toujours
des théories que nous pratique pas ça on
pratique pas les théories du 11
septembre Pr simplement le fait que le
général Westley Clark a fait des
déclarations vous vous les avez entendu
on on les affichera à l'écran en
postmontage d'accord si le général
Westley clar qui était quand même si mes
souvenirs sont mon l'ancien chef
d'état-major des troupes de l'OTAN en
Europe il était aussi viré du Pentagon
alors c'est pas quelqu'un qui juste se
promène et enfin qui est bien
respecté là-bas c'est vraiment quelqu'un
qui qui a été viré et qui n'est pas
apprécié ah bah c'est sûr que sil fait
fuuiter des mémos secrets défens ils ont
pas dû la PR ass souv et donc c'est mais
c'est aussi très doutable par qu'il a
vraiment beaucoup de accès à des gens
qui importent vraiment mais alors pour
répondre à à votre question eu il y a
trois mondes un type de monde que en
gros à Washington les gens comme moi
mais aussi les gens qui travaillent dans
des thing Tang qui jouent avec le le
premier monde c'est un monde unipolaire
hein et en gros le l'IRAC et les
néoconservateurs voulaient construire à
travers cette intervention ou prolonger
au moins le monde unipolaire ça veut
dire il y a juste un pôle c'est les
États-Unis mais pour rester le seul pôle
au monde il faut toujours démontrer de
la force donc vous vous faites référence
au PNAC c'est ça plan for new American
century voilà exactement et et l'idée
ici c'est en gros
pourquoi pourquoi il avait la la la
Première Guerre mondiale c'était était
un monde multipolaire il avait
l'Allemagne la Russie la France
l'Angleterre et ça et et mais quand il y
a des PES comme ça on peut pas créer un
équilibre c'est très très difficile de
créer des équilibres Bismark a su le
faire mais bom quand il il est parti he
tout est explosé et ensuite il a le un
un monde bipolaire pendant la seconde
pendant la gerre froide on était dans un
monde bipolaire mais là aussi c'est plus
stable queun monde multi bipolaire mais
ça a aussi des difficultés parce qu'on a
toujours voilà besoin de de balancing he
il faut toujours regarder l'autre et des
deux côtés il se créent des des des
images très profondes de
d'ennemis et donc aux États-Unis la
préférence des des certaines élites
c'est le monde unipolaire mais en même
temps ils sont très conscients que c'est
très difficile et notamment en fait au
lieu de établir et ou renforcer euh le
monde unipolaire à travers l'Irak et
aussi l'Afghanistan et l'intervention a
provoqué exactement le contraire hein
parce que les États-Unis n'a pas pu
démontrer la force euh en gros ils ont
démontré la faiblesse parce qu'ils
étaient pas capable de vraiment
conquérir euh le pays et voilà c'est
encore le désastre là-bas dans le proche
orient donc en gros euh les États-Unis
maintenant ils ont adapté euh l'image F
le du d'un futur euh euh bipolaire hein
mais pour les États-Unis et c'est le
grand contraire je trouve euh quand
compare ça avec avec les Européens euh
les deux pôles c'est clairement le
Pacifique alors surtout la Chine et euh
et les États-Unis et donc pour pour les
États-Unis le grand ou la grande
question c'est en fait que fait l'Europe
hein parce que là l'Europe de la défense
qu'est-ce que vous l'Europe en général
mais surtout l'Europe parce que elle
enfin les États-Unis veulent bien
entendu que l'Europe fait partie de du
camp de l'Ouest hein alors si on a deux
pôles le pôle Chine et le pôle
États-Unis pour l'EUR pour pour l'Europe
évidemment si c'est selon les désir
états-uni fait partie du camp états-uni
hein et donc pour l'Europe ici il faut
toujours enfin et moi je trouve qu'il y
a pas c de réflexion hein mais il faut
bien réfléchir si on veut vraiment faire
partir de
de
cette de cette enfin de coalition
alliance de cette coalition alliance
voilà mais à quel à quel titre à titre
non mais en gros c'est c'est exactement
le monde comme Val ou
comme c'est c'est un de une une une
réplication une copie du monde pendant
la guerre froide exactement même chose
exactement la même chose juste l'ennemi
maintenant c'est la Chine et pas la
Russie alors on a j'ai on a quelques
copains bien informés à Washington qui
reviennent des États-Unis qui nous
disent exactement la même chose c'estàd
qu'il y a une mentalité de de guerre
froide sous stéroïde dans la génération
des 40 55 ans c'est-à-dire la génération
qui était soit nos grands frères soit
nos pères plus jeunes pour
certains avec cette cette mentalité
guerrière
comment ça se passe au niveau de
l'Europe de la défense comment l'Europe
va se positionner par rapport à ça
est-ce que l'Europe va suivre et quel
est votre avis sur ce qui se passe avec
la
Russie on voit la Russie encerclée par
la l'OTAN physiquement parlant encerclé
vous étudiez toutes les les positions de
géolocalisation des bases de
l'OTAN on sent que la Russie est un
petit peu prise entre le marteau
l'enclum mais on voit que la Crimée que
le bouclier antimissile avant
Pologne ça se rapproche et on voit la
situation vraiment seendre alors on a eu
quelques contacts avec les Russes les
Russes sont encore un petit peu serein
mais quand même déploie des systèmes de
défense de la Syrie jusqu'à l'Arctique
comment ça va se terminer selon
vous alors toujours cette une
alternative à au monde qui est projeté
par les Américains c'est le monde
multipolaire c'est toujours une option
même si pour pour les Américains en ce
moment c'est pas vraiment un monde qu'il
désirent ou même qu'ils imaginent he
c'est enfin en réalité bien sûr c'est
toujours une une alternative alors donc
pour l'Europe il faut au moins à
niveau intellectuel il faut se demander
alors veut-on
devenir le le partenaire des États-Unis
dans leur lutte contre la Chine disons
ou
n'est-il pas préférable de créer un un
monde multipolaire et
donc créer un pôle européen
ou d'autres hein alors on va essayer de
se faire un scénario un peu noir et je
vais vous demander de réagir à ce
scénario là j'ai rien préparé ça va
venir comme ça va venir alors la
situation économique sur les marchés
financiers se dégradent les prix du
pétrole dégringolent le budget de la
Russie s fond les budgets des des
producteurs de pétrole s'effondre les
flux migratoires tant économiques que
duû au conflit s'accélère euh ça
déstabilise toutes les tous les pays
basés sur les les les routes de flux
migratoires une balcanisation de des
politique européenne avec une
augmentation puissante ferme et profonde
de l'extrême droite un repli identitaire
est-ce que vous pensez que ça va être
très gouvernable tout ça au niveau
européen ça va être très gouvernable au
niveau européen ça c'est votre question
au niveau européen ou puis ensuite mais
c'est pas gouvernable mais donc c'est
exactement cette question qu'il faut se
poser alors parce que si on on crée pas
une Europe de défense hein alors le
monde futur est déjà fait hein ce soit
unipolaire ou bipolaire hein c'est fait
heinas et donc mais peut-être c'est
peut-être c'est désirable moi j'ai pas
une une opinion propre vous avez vous
avez une vision anthropologique
c'est-à-dire non ENF moi euh je enfin
j'étais j'étais pas vivante disons
pendant la guerre Frid euh pour moi
c'est très difficile donc juste à partir
de de la littérature de juger comment
c'était et c'est vraiment un monde
bipolaire est préférable à un monde
multipolaire pour moi
euh je sais pas pratiquement je sais pas
théoriquement j'ai mes idées mais
pratiquement je sais pas je trouve ça
très difficile même nous en tant
qu'Européens euh on peut aussi dire que
on on a des avantages de monde
unipolaire plutôt hein parce que on est
quand même des amis des Américains pour
pour nous c'est plus facile de parler
avec les Américains par exemple que avec
les Chinois je crois enfin c'est au moin
il a on va essayer on va essayer on des
liens
culturels qu' ont je dirais quand même
plus plus prochesin euh mais moi je
trouve en tant que européen au moins il
faut faire le choix euh euh conscient
hein il faut réfléchir parce que sinon
on va juste suivre les choix des autres
notamment comment réfléchir sans une
autonomie de pensée est-ce que vous
pensez pas qu'il y a une projection de
la doctrine américaine au sein même de
nos élites c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
vraiment une grande partie American
minded est-ce que c'est pas compliqué de
pouvoir avoir cette autonomie de penser
à cause de
ça moi j'habite au États-Unis maintenant
quoi presque 8 ans et je crois
l'autonomie c'est à chacun de le prendre
de le saisir de se battre peut-être pour
le prendre absolument on peut je crois
passer du temps partout mais ce qui se
passe ici dans la tête en tant qu'aland
pardon excusez-moi en tant qu'allemande
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la décision
d'Angela Merkel de prolonger les
sanctions contre la
Russie vous savez l'Allemagne passe par
un temps extrêmement intense en ce
moment ça a commencé avec avec plus ou
moins la Russie mais aussi c en gros moi
j'ai je parle beaucoup au diplomates
notamment à Washington et là c'est très
intéressant parce que c'est quand même
encore un des centres de pouvoir au
monde et là le statut despis est assz
facilement touchable he si par exemple
c'est très facile d'avoir un un un
rendez-vous avec avec le vice-président
ça veut dire pour ces pays le son
pouvoir voir sa puissance a augmenté et
là quand je parle aux diplomates
étrangers mais qu'ils ont à Washington
ils me disent tous que pour l'Allemagne
ça a énormément changé là ça fait
peut-être 2 3 mois 2 3 ans désolé quand
pour l'Allemagne est vraiment
devenu un pays
clé à Washington c'était aussi parce
qu'il avait une croissance économique
l'Allemagne enfin c'est le grand
contraste avec la France il y a une
vraie croissance économique un vrai boom
économique hein euh mais en même temps
bien bien entendu avec avec la
croissance économique il y a aussi
ensuite euh une
euh voilà une prise de conscience euh
de on pourrait dire des responsabilités
mais aussi de vouloir euh s'engager et
vouloir entendre sa voix dans No
relations internationales vous vous vous
parlez d'entendre sa voix euh quand la
NSI écoute s Angela Merkel jusqu'au plus
profond de ses
communications les Allemands ont perçu
ça comment ils se sont sentis violés par
leur fameux alliés
américain les les Américains ou la
Russie non les Américains ont écouté
Angela Merkel euh non je crois les les
américains ils aiment bien ils aiment
bien écouter Merkel parce que elle
est non mais elle est pas
elle est pas la un leader
flamboyant dangereux hein
elle est elle est responsable et en fait
c'est pour ça que la NSA doit la écouter
vous connaissez la NSA oui bien sûr mais
en gros disons les améri les Américains
apprécie Merquel beaucoup et notamment
par exemple là il y a quand même une
vraie ménesse que euh l'Angleterre sort
de l'Union européenne le brexit le
brexit et là le pont ou le le pays qui
était encore le plus proche aux
États-Unis dans européenne c'est
toujours
l'Angleterre mais au cas où l'Angleterre
va sortir moi je suis sûr que
l'Allemagne va remplacer cette place qui
a normalement
toujours appartenu al c'est c'est une
place mais c'est aussi une place de
cheval de tro aussi dans la politique
américaine
mais ensuite euh les américains ils sont
euh seulement aussi puissants que nous
les
Europ non sont faibles et aussi laisse
euh
ENF Paris je vais vous poser encore deux
dernières questions euh la dernière sera
donner un conseil au nouvell au
nouvelles génération sur internet un
conseil pour endurcir leur esprit
critique donc ça c'est votre dernière
question mais l'avant-dernière celle que
je vous pose maintenant euh en tant
qu'universitaire euh
femme c'est pas trop dur oui c'est dur
ouais c'est même c'est scandaleux
d'ailleurs que ce soit dur h parce queon
est à peu près de la même génération euh
comment ça se fait qu'encore à notre
époque euh ce soit euh cette politique
de primitif parce qu'il faut être
primitif pour euh ne pas écouter ce
qu'il y a dans la tête d'une femme
oui tout à fait he et donc je peux juste
dire que toutes les femme oui c'est TR
c'est très dur il faut lutter mais ça
vaut le coup quand même ça vaut le coup
absolument il faut il faut hein on a pas
d'autre option mais en fait je crois la
la difficulté enfin pour moi
la la plus grande c'était que
euh vous savez si un homme est prof par
exemple à mone hein il y a il a beaucoup
de filles beaucoup de femmes qui
diraient oh waouh mais c'est magnifique
quel génie j'exagère he mais il a
énormément de respect pour pour une
femme comme moi c'est
euh c'est
intimidating et et ça euh ça me fait du
mal qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
aider il faut moi je suis pour une
politique de discrimination positive
parce que il faut créer des role models
hein et n'importe quelle femme dans la
politique c'était c'est une c'est une
bonne femme c'est très pour moi sans
gens comme condoliss rice comme Madelin
Albright comme samanta power comme
Angela Merkel TR cher parce que là elle
fa top bon elle est encore tu vois je l'
pas trop connu hein j'étais trop jeune
mais sont les femmes comme ça moi je
pourrais pas faire ce que je fais en ces
moments c'est vraiment des des leaders
de absolument oua
alors nous on a côtoyé quelques femmes
de pouvoir et on trouve qu'elles sont
pires que les hommes c'estàd encore plus
dur que les hommes
elles sont elles sont blindées et elles
ont oublié de cette sensibilité que nous
les hommes on a oublié peut-être est-ce
que vous vous endurcissez pas à tel
point que vous en oubliez votre
féminité vous
savez quand quand je suis la seule et ça
m'arrive souvent quand je suis la seule
femme autour d'une table et je et je dis
quelque chose et ensuite il y a un homme
plus moins monâge peut-être un peu plus
vieux qui répète exactement la même
chose hein que moi j'ai dis et tout le
monde applaudit le mec et ignore mon
commentaire qui était avant hein ça me
montre qu'il y a une discrimination
touttale hein et qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire dans ce moment qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire hein si si on est douce
hein avec un
souris ça change rien alors t il faut
quand même venez vous réfugier venez
vous réfugier sur Internet on va vous
protéger d'accord merci j'apprécie un
conseil pour les jeunes jeunes
générations un autre peut-être
et il faut vraiment réfléchir dans quel
monde on veut
habiter parce que là c'est très facile
aux États-Unis au moins il y a une telle
conscience qu'ils ont le leader euh au
monde hein que bon je dirais pas tout le
monde mais au moins euh l'élite
réfléchit euh au futur moi je trouve ici
c'est toujours medling through ouais euh
et euh et ça c'est pas une option marine
que merci merci à vous
[Musique]